if you had to make an r b super group
with two other singers who would you put
in your super group one album your t t
what was it TGT
how many times how many genuine dude two
more three three [__] you gotta pick two
other guys to be in a super group which
is crazy
um
bro that's crazy like I had to say usher
and CB
I mean that's that's crazy yeah I'm
gonna have to say that this is like I
mean yeah that's those are the two right
answers you say r b and then like
Generations like I feel like
that's like Usher's gonna grab a little
bit older than me yeah CB's gonna grab
mine and younger and then I'm like in
the middle grabbing it you know what I'm
saying but this detection the voice text
phone in the jail verse from R Kelly
yeah Hey listen I ain't gonna lie to you
I bumped his [__] every [__] day me
too every [__] day
listen I am not ashamed to say I can
separate the art from the art it comes
to an artist who has been able to make
every type of song and have every type
of have fun or baby man come on man I
believe I can fly to half on a baby to
you know
it's just he's just the goat he's the
guy but you know listen it's him a
rusher because I went to Usher show in
Vegas have you seen his Vegas show of
course I'm just talking about but you
can't compare them to bro
you can't compare Usher and R Kelly in
terms of being the ghost of R B Because
all right Kelly his pin
I agree Kelly's got the greatest pen
ever probably he wrote for Michael
Jackson like
baby making songs pop records like a big
wreck like but you know what you know
what R Kelly never got though I don't
know
he never got like a OMG he didn't really
participate in that but he can't come
out in that time no but I was gonna
because but think about it right well
listen I mean Usher came out in 94. no
but but
R Kelly was not he was not incarcerated
in 2010 when every R B artist was doing
shitty EDM songs do you remember that
era right absolutely that don't count
that's cheat code [__] I don't think it
counts like when Neo and Pitbull were
put out I can't worldly you can't have
the Army conversation at that point
that's out so listen I agree with you
for this I think R Kelly's the greatest
of all time
I think when you factor in everything
okay
I give Usher all his life I think it's
got to be Usher he gave me my flowers at
the shows shows I just think Usher is
like a like amazing not only is he
got the classics but he also the
entertainment because like I've seen R
Kelly live when I was a little kid I saw
him not I saw him in Nas and it was
great that's different I don't know I
think but it was like categorize it I
feel like R Kelly was more like he was
like more like when you watched him live
it was like kind of like watching a
rapper he had background dances right
like Usher as a performer no we're not
talking [__] skates bro Christmas out
here a superstar he's a performer he's
like a he's a pop r b he's an r b
Superstar what are we talking about just
R B music I have to Crown R Kelly I have
to I respect that and and I agree
and there's a lot I mean there's so many
great artists man I think it's crazy I
think the three names that I I mean and
this is just speaking of somebody who
was born in 1987 but then you got a
crown CB2 listen I was gonna say the
three Chris Brown ushering R Kelly yeah
you got a crowd CB man like he he's an
Elio I think he's the most alien
talented artist he him ever I think it's
him and it's Jamie Foxx because I'm just
thinking Talent I'm not talking about
music I just mean
Talent inside of a human being yeah for
sure Chris Brown can paint a mural on a
building
he can dance yeah maybe all-time great
dancer him and Michael Jackson he could
sing he could write he could wrap his
ass off he could act ish oh you know he
was all right uh and then he could hoop
he could I mean I mean listen then
there's Jamie Foxx who can do all that
and he's one of the greatest stand-up
comedians of all time yeah man he's one
of the greatest actors ever like it's a
lot of it's a lot of talent and and our
culture bro it's a lot of talent it's
crazy would you uh would you ever do a
Vegas residential residency show one day
um yes I definitely would for sure
because
I just feel like there's so many pockets
that I can go into you know I've done
Broadway I've done acting I've toured I
mean when it comes to doing residencies
you really have time to put together a
show and perfect it yeah like a real
entertainment show like and when it
comes to that like I I love that space
so I definitely would and I would
incorporate all of my talents in one
show for sure
um can you tell me uh how how nervous
were you the first time back in the day
because I was just talking to my boy and
we were trying to go over we were
talking about how Roxy and big TIG are
very slept on in terms of when we talk
about the the best host of photosystem
park because everyone says Adrian free
and I'm like Roxy and Tig did their
thing too but how nervous were you the
very first time going on 106 and Park
like were you nervous like what was that
day like pulling up to 106 and Park bro
I think it's more anxious because it's
your peers you know what I'm saying it's
like 106 apart I felt like I was going
back to high school and seeing all my
peers like you go in the audience they
got people your age yes kids it was like
like teenagers it's like you it feels
like a party like you know what I'm
saying so I wasn't nervous it was just
more anxious to like and exciting and
[__] because this is like I don't even
know if they have they don't even have
shoes like that no more like I just
watched a random performance pop up on
my story of like [__] was fun man it was
when you when you went to 106 it was
like a reunion it was like an event yeah
I saw do you remember when genuine
performed and they had to respond it was
like yeah little ass stage they did all
of that all the stages like a little
bigger than this table right here crazy
man it's classic so main one is out it's
going crazy it's featuring Tyga it's uh
it's featuring Lil Wayne
um are you gonna have any uh sort of uh
obviously like you got 3 000 unreleased
songs so that's you know it's crazy
Jesus uh you already have the next
single pick though nah nah nah I don't
have any Pig I like to stay fresh bro
like I'm going in the lab and cooking
for that would you like for these next
few shows I'm probably lacking in it
just yeah would you ever uh reunite with
the uh Scott Storage here for sure yeah
I talked to Scott two weeks ago we got
records that could possibly be something
you know what I'm saying already but we
definitely tap it back in for sure I'll
just talked to a lot of cigarette smoke
in that session well Scott yo Scott's
he'll smoke down them cigs and then he's
a he's you know what's crazy well he in
the studio with me he don't really he
don't really smoke he'll go outside the
studio no no he'll smoke outside smoke
cigarettes like that I see him smoking
weed I don't smoke weed and he'll smoke
cigarettes I don't see him smoke
cigarettes George is a sweetheart man
he's a great guy I can't wait for them
to make
the movie about his life crazy because
it's gonna be in [__] insane I don't
even want it to be a movie I want it to
be like a HBO Max original it's so many
legendary I want 50 Cent to be the
executive producer like the sky storage
store it could be fire because he had
sex with everybody first everybody like
Ray J did not hit it first time
right anyway
all right so look the single is going
crazy is there going to be uh anything
uh visual wise come in with it video
just came out video just dropped us out
right now so yeah we're going up um and
then obviously I'm on the way what made
you get back with the major because
you're obviously back you're you're with
epic which you know you in a different
capacity you know it's more like a
partnership and really just you know
Sylvia Zeke you know what I'm saying
we've been talking about you know
working for a minute
and I'm a business partner Andy AKA 365
management like we we decided to
collectively go that route because you
know we just been put I just put a lot
of work in on the ground you know what
I'm saying and just like learning the
the business aspect of this [__] for
like the last seven years yeah in the
independent space right and um yeah I
just felt like it was time to to have an
addition to the team 11. I like the I
like the house over there I like who's
there yeah you know what I'm saying
except for
no I'm excited for you man but look the
singles I'll go crazy go support it and
then uh make sure you get tickets to go
watch your Neo and Robin Thicke yes sir
on tour that's gonna be a fun concert
should be a lot of ladies in there it
has been every show yeah every [__]
show go run that up uh appreciate you
pulling up brother always man yeah
congrats on your and everything you're
doing too man Mario got the hustle boom
[Music]